I cannot wait to see Ben and his brother
Casey at the Globes on Sunday now this
is going to be a partay because remember
this is the award show where they serve
drinks all night long and the stars
really get to cut loose throughout proof
well here are the funniest moments we
will never forget and the categories are
honestly I was told I was presenting
alone first up the contenders for most
outrageous moment by presenter I don't
know if an actress can do her best work
until I slept with her
our winner Waldron you want me to yeah I
have the nails yeah get after you got
the Globes to UM next the globe's are
known for catching stars in the act
Christine Lahti got it the worst in 1998
I was in the back turtlemom same thing
happened to Renee Zellweger just three
years later my mom and I almost didn't
have it seemed like a great time the
lights went down they said you know
commercial break and I thought hey Meryl
Streep is the Golden Globe Queen so
shout outs are to be expected Oh
what does it say I beat Meryl who do you
want to take a picture the best Mel joke
happened in 2013 what does that say
Cheryl
Muriel Muriel Muriel Street the hosts
are known to take aim at the audience
we're still laughing at this one from
2014 hosts Tina Fey and Amy Poehler
gravity is nominated for best film it's
the story of how George Clooney would
rather float away into space and die
than spend one more minute with a woman
his own age the best of all this is live
TV so of course we've got some favorite
prompter fails how's it ready doing good
all right crap they put up the wrong
stuff on the teleprompter our winner is
here comes oh here it's gone yeah thank
you
this is why we love this evening
[Music]
you